[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: Hi, my
name is Shyam Govardhan.
I'm a strategic cloud engineer
from Sydney, Australia.
On stage, I have
Henry Suryawirawan,
who is also a strategic cloud
engineer from Singapore.
And we have one of our cloud
partners in Gopi Kudaravalli.
He's based here in the US.
So we're really
excited to be here,
to be talking about how
you can build some really
cool, innovative
internet-of-things applications
using Cloud Firestore.
Cloud Firestore is
the next generation
document-oriented database built
specifically for the cloud.
It allows you to spin
up real-time, stateful
applications in a
matter of minutes.
It is so easy.
It allows you to keep
your data in sync
across multiple devices,
even when they're offline.
We'll get into more
details very soon.
So this session is
really about building
real-time, stateful
applications.
Well, what exactly do
we mean by stateful?
Stateful essentially means
that the computer or program
keeps track of the
state of interactions
by setting values in a
storage field designated
for that purpose.
So we're going to look at
the architectural choices
and technical
considerations in building
an internet-of-things
application from the ground up,
from scratch.
And we're going to
marvel at the ease of use
and simplicity of Firestore.
Who's used Firestore here?
Yay.
Who likes Firestore?
Everybody, right?
Yeah.
So look, fundamentally,
it allows
you to keep your data and
sync across multiple devices.
And you can literally
spin up IoT applications
in a matter of minutes.
We're going to
explore, as I said,
some of the
architectural choices
and technical considerations
in building an IoT application,
marvel at the ease of use
and simplicity of Firestore.
So with that, IoT is really
made up of intelligence.
It's really about people,
applications, and devices
working together to
deliver a smart experience.
The smartphone is a perfect
example of an IoT device.
It allows us to convert
data to information.
Smart IoT devices take
it to a whole new level.
They allow us to convert data
to information, information
to knowledge,
knowledge to wisdom,
and use the wisdom to make
meaningful decisions that
will improve the
quality of our lives.
They allow us to glean
actionable insights
in the moments that
matter, in the moments
of commercial intent.
So really, speaking
of devices, you know,
it's really important
for us to understand
the subtle distinction
between a microcontroller
and a microprocessor.
A microcontroller,
or an MCU, they
tend to be fairly
less expensive.
They are simpler to set
up, simpler to operate,
and Arduino, ESP 32,
Particle are some examples
of microcontrollers.
A connected coffee
machine, for instance,
only needs to concern itself
with simple routines and tasks.
So a microcontroller
is perfectly
suited for that use case.
A microprocessor,
on the other hand,
they tend to be a little
bit more expensive.
The Raspberry Pi is a great
example of a microprocessor.
So they allow you to install a
full-fledged operating system,
and they provide features,
like package management.
You can install additional
software and stuff.
And they also
allow multitasking.
So robotics, drones, augmented
reality are some typical use
cases of where you would use
and deploy microprocessors.
And it's really important
to understand the difference
between microcontrollers
and microprocessors,
because the tools,
techniques, and protocols
that will be used to
develop the application
will decide whether
you'd be deploying it
on a microcontroller
or a microprocessor.
So that fundamental
decision will
determine what
tools, technologies,
and protocols you'll be using.
So with that, I'll
quickly hand over
to Henry, who'll be
talking about Firestore.
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN:
Thank you, Shyam.
So at the heart of this demo
is actually Cloud Firestore.
So what is Cloud Firestore?
To put it simply,
Cloud Firestore
is a serverless, NoSQL,
document database
that is built for the cloud.
But it's much more than that.
Cloud Firestore is more of
a back-end as a service that
not only gives you the
database, but also provides
the infrastructure
that handles moving
stateful data between the
cloud and your application
and devices, which naturally
leads us into how it's also
an embedded database
that continues to power
your application and
devices to the cloud.
So let's dive deeper
into Cloud Firestore.
As mentioned, it's a
document-oriented database,
which means that it's
designed to store and manage
semi-structured data,
so just JSON objects.
It's completely schemaless.
Meaning that you don't need
to design your schema upfront,
so that you can continue
to evolve your application
without having to worry about
coordinating structural changes
to your database.
And you can update
your application
as and when you need it.
Google fully manages the
infrastructure for you,
so that you can focus on
building your application
rather than thinking
about scheduling downtime,
so you can install
your database upgrades
or even installing the latest
security vulnerability patches.
It gives you a full
serverless experience,
so that you don't need to
think about machine sizes,
like CPU, RAMs, number of
nodes, replicas, disks,
or even networking.
All of these are packaged with
pay-as-you-go pricing that can
scale down to zero
when you don't need it.
Cloud Firestore is
super-simple to setup.
You enable it from
your project, download
and install the
SDK in your apps,
and then you're ready to go.
Like I said, it's more
than just a database.
You can access it directly
from your application
without having to write
any middle tier that
sits in between.
You can secure this
direct connection
with a combination of
declarative security rules
and integration with
Firebase authentication.
What these rules allow is that
you can manage the request that
comes into Firestore.
You can allow it
or deny it based
on what the request is,
who the sign-in user is,
and how it compares with
the information stored
in the database.
And what makes Cloud
Firestore more than just
a database is the real-time
update capability.
Cloud Firestore doesn't
give you just the database,
but also handles the pushing
of the updates, synchronization
of the changes from the database
with your app in real time.
So we're going to
see that in a demo
as well, which brings me to the
last embedded database piece.
Firebase is the case for the
Firestore actively cached
data in your app, so
that you can write, read,
listen to, or query data, even
when the device is offline.
The mobile and JavaScript SDKs
for iOS, Android, and browsers
give you the local
embedded database
that syncs with a cloud when
there's an active connection.
It also has this nifty feature
called latency compensation,
which basically handles pushing
of the updates to the cloud,
and then unblocking the
UI and also giving you
more freedom in your app.
Talking about
Firebase SDKs, there
are some crucial components
that are also included inside.
The first is Firebase
authentication,
which supports signing in
user based on passwords, phone
numbers, and other popular
identity providers,
such as Google, Facebook,
Twitter, or GitHub.
Security rules, as mentioned,
provide access control and data
validation in a simple
and yet expressive format.
Cloud Functions
lets you configure
events, such as when you add
new document to your collection.
And you can trigger a
function from there.
So it lets you extend your
application even further
into the cloud.
We have implemented some
Cloud Functions for the demo
later on for the real-time
object detection system,
and we're going
to see it shortly.
Next, Firebase Cloud
Messaging lets you reliably
deliver messages at no cost.
And lastly, Firebase
Remote Config,
it allows you to change
the behavior of your app
without requiring users
to download an app update.
You can use this for scenarios,
such as A/B testing, doc
launches, canary release,
or feature toggle.
And Cloud Firestore is not
just for Firebase project.
You can use it for
server side as well.
It's supports multiple
service or languages,
like C Sharp, Java, Go,
and so on and so forth.
It supports both
REST and gRPC APIs,
making it accessible
from any environment.
It's designed for
reliability, with five
9's availability target.
The multi-region
replication ensures
that your data is durable
and highly available,
even in the face of
the natural disasters.
And it can scale
on demand, based
on the most demanding
workloads that you have,
so that you don't need to
think about connection pools.
And it's highly suited
for scalable computing
infrastructure, such as
Kubernetes Engine or App
Engine.
And you can both scale
up when you need it,
or scale down when
you don't need it.
So I'll hand over
to Gopi, who will
run through the architecture
and implementation of our demo.
GOPI KUDARAVALLI: Thanks, Henry.
So let's look at
the architecture
and implementation.
So if we look at this, we're
actually using Firebase.
Firebase is like a
Swiss army knife.
It has a file store.
It gives you a storage.
It gives you a cloud function.
It gives you
hosting, and it also
give you authentication and
authorization capabilities.
So what we're doing here
is, we have an IoT device,
which captures telemetry
data from the sensors mounted
on the [INAUDIBLE] and it
pushes the data in real time
to Cloud Firestore.
On the other hand, the picture
captured from the camera module
is pushed to the
cloud storage, which
is basically Firebase Storage.
So Firebase Storage
is essentially
a Google Cloud Storage
location, which
is accessible through
Firebase admin SDKs.
So as the pictures keep arriving
in the Firebase Storage,
we actually written a simple
Cloud Function that gets
triggered.
The Cloud Function basically
invokes region API calls.
And all it does is
it detects objects
within the image,
in essence, labels
to their detected objects.
So all these outputs are
basically written back
to the Cloud Firestore.
The user interface basically is
hosted using Firebase Hosting.
And all the authentication
is basically
done using Firebase
authentication.
So there are a lot of
providers, which you can use.
So right now, in our
demo application,
we are using Google
Cloud auth sign-in
For authorization, we're
actually writing security rules
for authorizing
access to services,
like Firestore,
Storage, et cetera.
So that's the simplistic
version of the architecture
that we've developed.
So you can basically extend
this simple architecture
to interact with your own fleet
of machine-learning services.
So if you look at the
machine learning spectrum,
on the left-hand side,
you have a whole range
of ease-of-use services,
like Vision APIs.
Or if you want to extend it more
customized to your use case,
you can basically
use Cloud RTML,
or you can further customize.
Bring your own data, build your
own models using Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
So how many of you like Python?
Can you raise your hands?
I like Python.
How many of you like Node.js?
OK.
And how many of you like Go?
And how many of you
don't like any of these?
Right.
So what we've done
is, the Cloud Function
that we have developed,
the initial version
was in Python 2.
And it was making traditional
synchronous calls.
So if you look at the
competence in Cloud Function,
we basically have
four major tasks,
which is an object detection,
a label detection, a web entity
detection, and URL generation.
So what we have done is we
have taken the initial version
of the Python code
developed by Shyam,
and we have kind of made it
asynchronous using Node.js.
You can, as well, make it
asynchronous using Python 3,
using async IO And if
you are a Go programmer,
you can basically
use Go routines.
So this is asynchronous
representation
of the Cloud Function
that we have developed.
And if I dive deep into
each of the functions
within the Cloud Function,
this is simple function
for object localization.
All it does is it
takes the image input
from the GCS bucket.
It instantiates an object
of Cloud Vision API.
And all it receives
is coordinates
of the bounding
boxes, which are just
the vertices of
the bounding boxes.
That's what we get as a response
out of object localization.
The next API is, we are actually
using object localization,
which is label detection, which
is basically assigning labels
based on the objects that are
detected within the image.
The third one is web
entity detection.
So for the image that you
actually give it as input,
it actually searches on
the web and gives you
labels for the image.
And finally, we have a
function for generating
signed URLs for the
images from Cloud Storage,
so that we can populate
that on top of the UI.
So if you observe, in Node,js,
what we're using is we are
implementing promises.
So basically, your
promise objects,
once they get resolved in
an asynchronous fashion,
we actually collate
all the responses,
create an image
document, which has
all the responses
from object detection,
to label detection, to
web entity direction,
to your signed URL.
And we basically
write this object
inside a predefined
collection in Cloud Firestore.
All right, so let's
look at the demo.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: Great.
Who is 100% believer
that live demos
at large conferences in front
of large audiences always work?
Well, we're going to
find out very soon.
So what you're looking at here
is a smart environment monitor
and an object-detection system.
So essentially, it's a rig
that are put up together,
and it features a
Raspberry Pi 3 Model B+.
Who's played with one of these?
Many of you.
OK, good.
Who's played with a Sense HAT?
Good, a few of you.
So you see the Raspberry Pi 3
Model B+ has those GPIO pins
at the top.
The Sense HAT here comes
with a bunch of sensors.
But the ones that I was
particularly interested in
is a gyroscope and
an accelerometer.
So what you can do is
essentially take the Raspberry
Pi and the Sense HAT and
connect them both together
like so using the GPIO pins.
And the third piece to
the puzzle is what's known
as a GrovePi+.
You can pick up the Raspberry
Pi 3 Model B+ for about 35 US
dollars.
Sense HAT is about
the same cost as well.
And this thing here,
GrovePi+, is from Seed Studio,
and it comes with a few
connectors that allow you
to hook up sensors.
So you have three
analog sensors,
connectors to the left.
You have digital sensors,
connectors at the bottom.
And you also have
other I2C connectors
on the right as well.
So essentially, the Sense
HAT and the GrovePi+ are
essentially know as HATs,
Hardware Attached at the Top.
So you can literally
take it and hook it
up directly on top of one
another, just like so.
And what I've ended up with
is basically exactly what
I've described over there.
And what I also have
is a bunch of sensors
connected to the entire rig.
So I have a light sensor on
the top left-hand corner.
It basically
detects fluctuations
in the light levels.
The sounds sensor, obviously,
detects the fluctuations
in the sound level.
The angle sensor, it's a knob.
It basically allows you
to twist it left or right.
And I'm using it to control
the rate of transmitting
telemetry data to Firestore.
You know, essentially, it's a
potentiometer, in electronics
terms.
So when you turn it all the
way up, it sends it fast.
And when you turn it
down, it sends it slower.
And here, you basically
have a flame sensor.
I was told that I couldn't
light a match or a lighter
here on stage, for
safety reasons,
so it ain't going to happen.
You also have a
button here as well.
When you press the button, the
web camera will take a photo.
And there is an
ultrasonic sensor,
and that sensor basically
checks the proximity reading.
So as you move an object
further or closer to it,
it will detect that.
And what actually happens
is, all of these readings
get uploaded, transmitted
to Firestore in real time.
And that's the beauty about it.
What use is an
environment monitor
if it's not in real time?
You don't want to know
that your house is
on fire five minutes ago.
You want to know if
anything is happening
right this very moment.
So real time nature is critical.
And it's for that very
reason I felt that Firestore
was a perfect fit.
I can't think of any other
solution that will give me
that feature and functionality.
So essentially,
this is basically
what my first
version looked like.
I plugged in all the sensors.
And as it says here,
my first version
also used Google IoT Core
and Google Pub/Sub as well.
Pub/Sub is an asynchronous
message-broking platform
from Google, which is part
of Google Cloud Platform.
And Google IoT
Core or allows you
to create a device
registry, a central registry
of all your IoT devices.
For this particular
use case, I just
stuck with Firestore, because
it was much simpler to demo.
And this here was the final
version of what I ended up.
So the previous version of
the smart environment monitor
only featured the six sensors.
The next version also
included Logitech webcam
connected to the USB
port of the Raspberry Pi.
And I also connected
a speaker to it.
In this instance,
I actually have
the audio connected to the
central audio speakers there.
I also have a little
travel router here.
So the entire rig basically
gets its IP address and internet
connectivity using
this travel router.
So I can just take it
around wherever I want.
So with that,
let's dive into it.
Henry here is going to focus--
if we could just focus on the
rig for me please, Michael.
Great.
So here, this is basically
what it looks like.
As you can see here, there is
a Raspberry Pi at the bottom.
You have a Sense HAT on top.
You have the Grove
Pi+ on top of it.
And you have all of the sensors
connected at the top over here,
and we will be
interacting with it.
Can we please
switch to my laptop?
OK, first things first.
I want to make sure that
everything is up and running.
I don't want to start a demo
and find out that everything's
broken behind the scenes.
Because, albeit, this is
a hack that I've created.
It's not a production
quality Samsung technology.
You can build this up
for about 100 bucks.
So anyway, first thing
I want to establish
is, is the process running?
So when I do that,
that basically
tells me that there is a
daemon, a process that's
running on the Raspberry Pi.
So essentially, a
daemon is a program
that basically runs constantly,
and the operating system
basically will restart it, if
for whatever reason, it dies.
OK, now, one other thing is,
as you can see from the status,
it is generating its log files.
It's generating a log file here.
So let me tail it.
So this is basically telling
me what the actual program,
the Python program, is doing.
Now, let me now
press the button.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
OK, you can now
see what happened.
I clicked the button.
The webcam captured a photo,
I think, of a few objects.
Hopefully, I'm aiming correctly.
The telemetry reading is
displayed in the log file.
It's telling me everything
from the light reading,
the sound level,
orientation, accelerometer,
and a few other things.
It's played a WAV file
for the shutter sound
to indicate that something
actually happened.
It's used the fs-web program
to basically capture the photo.
And it's uploaded the photo
to Google Cloud Storage, which
is essentially like a giant file
system sitting in the cloud.
So you can just
upload files to it
and not worry about
it, because you
can have the cloud handle it.
So that's pretty
much what I've done,
so let's do it a few more times.
You know, let's try
and see how Ralph is
responding to this whole thing.
He seems pretty happy.
This is from "Wreck-It Ralph."
So there you go.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
There you go.
How about this
elephant from India?
[CAMERA CLICKS]
Or this "Little
Mermaid" lion from--
[CAMERA CLICKS]
And I don't know if it's going
to detect the Eiffel Tower.
Let's check.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
And there is a horse as well.
OK, there you have it.
Put them all together.
Ralph in the middle.
Let's snap away.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
Let's take a picture
of the audience.
Smile.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
Good.
One more.
[CAMERA CLICKS]
OK, you get the drift, right?
Pretty easy, pretty obvious.
So what?
No big deal.
Now the partners--
just bear with me,
can you, just one moment?
Our partners at
Quantiphi, Nilay Kamat,
in particular, he's a very
talented software engineer.
Unfortunately, he wasn't able
to be here at this conference.
He's come up with a
beautiful dashboard,
and it shows you all of the
photos that I just captured.
That's real time for you.
A cheap little contraption,
with commodity hardware,
a $35 Raspberry Pi and a webcam
capture photo, publish it,
publish it at will to the cloud.
And you have a cloud
function that is constantly
listening to those events.
And it's basically gone and
done object detection for you.
It's done object
detection, and it's
drawn a bounding box around
the object that it detected.
And it's used a localized
object feature of Vision API.
And it's also used a label
detection feature of Vision API
to come up with a word cloud.
And essentially, look,
I'm not a machine.
I'm not an AI expert.
I'm not into machine learning.
I'm just a software engineer.
But I was able to literally
leverage Google Cloud Platform
to spin up a fairly useful,
practical, so to speak,
object detection surveillance
system, as well as
an environment
monitor, with little to
no effort, very little code.
You don't need to have
a PhD in AI to come up
with something like this.
Let's see if it detected
anything about you guys.
Oh, there's people here--
surprise.
And one of them is smiling.
Even-- oh, there's a convention.
There's a convention.
There's a crowd.
There's an audience.
That's pretty impressive.
Let's see what
happened over here.
It's detected an
Indian elephant.
So if you ask me, that's
all pretty impressive.
So this is Vision API
in action for you.
OK, it's also detected
Wreck-It Ralph,
and it's a person with
muscle and physical fitness.
Come on.
Tell me you're impressed.
Give me some sign
that you're impressed.
Come on.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I'm working hard over here.
So you guys get it.
OK, the next thing
I want to show you
is-- you get the
idea about what's
happened behind the scenes.
Vision API, localized
objects, which gives you
the bounding boxes, x-y
coordinates and whatnot
and also the label detection.
Now, let's look at
telemetry stats.
Look at how fast the telemetry
readings are getting updated.
Now that, again,
ladies and gentlemen,
is real time for you.
I cannot think of another
technology that is better
suited than Firebase
or Firestore,
in this particular instance,
where I can just pump real-time
telemetry data to the cloud for
it to get visualized in real
time just like that.
[APPLAUSE]
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN:
Move something.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: Hmm?
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN: Move
something-- your hand, lights.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: Oh, yeah.
You do you want me to do?
Oh, light.
Oh, yeah.
OK, good.
Henry here has a
good suggestion.
Check that out.
I'm moving my hand
right above the light.
Check out the light reading
on the top right-hand corner.
It's gone all the way down.
And take my hand up--
755.
How quick was that?
That's pretty cool, right?
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
OK, look, I can
go on about this.
There is also a--
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN: D3.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: D3 dashboard.
This is an earlier version of
the dashboard that we created,
and this also shows you things
like the ultrasonic sensor.
So for instance,
if I move my hand,
you can see the sonic
reading fluctuate.
That's real time for you again.
You need to know
what's happening
right this very moment across
devices, across geographies, as
and when it happened.
I can't think of
any other technology
that'll make it happen,
other than the Firestore.
If I pressed a button,
[CAMERA CLICKS]
How long did it take
for the button to flash?
Instantaneous.
If I move this rig,
see the globes move.
That's the gyroscope
and accelerometer
in action for you.
We demo other sensors.
Let's look at how it's
working behind the scenes.
This here is Firebase console.
You can go to Firebase and
just look up Firebase console.
That is how fast the
telemetry readings
are being sent by this
Raspberry Pi to the cloud--
at one-second intervals,
extremely fast.
Here, you have the
accelerometer readings,
and you also have light
reading over there.
You have the orientation
with the gyroscope readings,
sonic level readings, which is
the proximity reading and so
forth, and temperature.
All this is happening rapidly.
You know all those
photos that we just took?
Where are they?
This is a collection.
Firestore basically
has this concept
of a collection and documents.
So essentially,
in this document,
you have multiple collections.
So you have multiple tags
assigned to that one photo.
So in this particular
case, you can see,
floor, flooring,
hardwood, and so forth.
You know, so it's pretty easy.
You can also see the
bounding box coordinates.
These are the diagonal
x and y-coordinates
so that we were able to
draw the bounding rectangle.
You can see what's
happening here.
We had events happening
on the Raspberry Pi.
It gets published in
real time to Firestore.
The image gets published
to Cloud Storage.
Cloud Function kicks in.
It does object detection.
It generates bounding
box rectangles,
and it does label
detection and so forth.
And you were able to see
all that instantaneously.
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN:
Four minutes left.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: No worries.
And then you also have this
thing called a Cloud Function.
OK, Cloud Function is basically
serverless technology.
This is basically
what it looks like.
So if I went into
Cloud Functions here,
let's look at Python.
And here, you have the source,
and this is basically it.
Look, Python, it's
trivial piece of code.
I don't have time to
actually go through it.
But it's literally
less than 100 lines
or 200 lines-- pretty easy.
But OK, this is
where the fun begins.
We want you all to
participate in this demo.
We'd like to gamify this.
We're going to give
you exclusive access
to two of the most
talented engineers in San
Francisco, my friend
Henry and Gopi over here.
Exclusive access
to these two guys,
who will give you a personal,
30-minute session to do what
you please with the IoT rig.
All you have to do--
you know that card
that was handed out to you?
Please scan the QR code
or visit next.shyamg.com.
And from the dropdown
box that you see there,
select one or more tags.
As you select one
or more tags, we
are keeping a tally of
who's clicking on what.
Could I please get you all to
participate in this live demo?
This is basically demonstrating
real-time IoT at scale,
in action.
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN: So
you go to image pool.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: So
basically, go to image pool
once you arrive there.
And click away.
Click away on different labels.
We have a couple more minutes.
If I could please get
you all to click away.
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN:
The more the better.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN:
Click as many times as
you want, because there
is a punchline to this.
There is a purpose to this.
OK, as you can see here,
as you select these labels,
the images get updated
instantaneously.
Are we good?
How much time do we have?
HENRY SURYAWIRAWAN:
Show the stats now.
SHYAM GOVARDHAN: OK, let's
now look at the stats.
Let's look at user stats.
And there you have it.
How long did that take,
ladies and gentlemen,
to come up with a live histogram
of all of the selections
that you made over
the last minute?
That, again, is
Firestore for you.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
Who is [INAUDIBLE]?
There you go.
He's the winner, so it seems.
So this is getting
updated in real time.
Thank you all for your support.
And I would personally like to
thank my partners at Quantiphi
for the great work.
I'd also like to
personally thank
my friend and very talented
engineer in India, who wasn't
able to be here, Nilay Kamat.
But please feel free to reach
out to us at the Quantiphi
booth after the session.
Thanks again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]